JENNY BROWN: In
our last video, we
talked about what makes the
Cloud Talent Solution Job
Search API a good
fit for improving
the quality of job searching.
Now, let's look at the best
ways to implement the API
into your job search solution
and go over planning details
to get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
One important thing to note
about the Job Search API
is that it's a search
index of your jobs.
This means it's intended to
work alongside your existing
database by mirroring
the contents
and searching against
it in a manner that's
optimized to find the most
relevant results to a search
query.
This means it acts something
like a middle layer
for the underlying system.
In order for the API to best
determine relevant search
results, it stores information
that you provide about the jobs
and uses a pretrained
machine learning model
with your provided data to
return relevant results.
Once the API is integrated
into your system,
your users will see high-quality
search results immediately.
For many businesses, this
improvement in search quality
is more than sufficient.
If you want to further
refine the ordering,
the API also offers
configuration options
as well as the ability to
further train the model.
We'll talk about these
in depth in later videos.
You'll want to make sure
that you keep your job
database as the
primary source of truth
and use the Job Search
API as a search index.
With that in mind,
let's take a look
at how to plan out
an implementation
so you can connect your job
solution to the Job Search API.
To get the data
into the API, you'll
connect it to your database,
but not to your front end
quite yet.
Using the Google
Client Library, which
is available in a
number of languages,
you can access the Job
Search API directly
or you can implement a custom
connector through the REST
or RPC interface.
Once connected, you
can start by sending
a list of jobs and
companies to the API, which
then analyzes and indexes
them into a searchable form.
When uploading the
data to the API,
it's important to consider
your capacity needs.
Capacity planning makes
sure the API can provide
the appropriate support for
all of the daily operations,
such as adding and deleting
jobs and companies.
Here are some
factors to consider
when looking at capacity.
How frequently are jobs
created, updated, and deleted?
How often do job
seekers receive alerts?
For both of these,
you'll need to estimate
the capacity for
batch data loads
as well as normal daily usage.
How frequently are job
seekers doing searches?
Capacity here should be measured
for peak and daily usage.
With capacity planning set
up you're in good shape
to start uploading data.
Once your data is uploaded,
the Job Search API
will be ready to use, thanks
to the built-in ML models.
When designing your
integration, it's
important to ensure that
your solution is built
in a fault-tolerant manner.
That way, if the
Job Search API Index
needs to be tweaked
for any reason,
you can route traffic
back to your existing back
end without interrupting your
users' job search experience.
We'll go through and share more
information and tips to help
you plan your implementation.
Stay tuned for our
next video where
we'll dive a little deeper
and look at configuring
search results from the API.
Thanks for watching.
And remember, when
looking for talent,
it's OK to keep your
head in the cloud.